okay so maybe I've been putting off
making this video for a little too long
well over the last couple of months I've
been exploring and watching through the
catalog of Dragonball films most of
which I've never seen
I stand up by watching the most
recommended by you guys then I tackle
the second most recommended and then I
force myself through the least popular
among them but today I'm going to be
forcing myself through what I expect to
be the worst session of movie watching
I've ever experienced why do I think
this well the movies that receive the
most and least votes do so for a reason
people either hate them or love them
either way there's something to be
gained
either through admiration or at the very
least a bit of humor poking fun at it
but when something is in the middle it
can be very boring so I have five more
left to cover well technically I have
six but I don't want to watch another
old Dragon Ball movie that recaps
moments around early tournament arcs how
does shoot a rolly with the DOE tonray
though all right we have five movies
left and those films are free of might
Lord slug the return of cooler super
Android 13 and early second coming I
haven't seen any of these films and to
kick things off we're diving straight
into the tree of might okay so not only
have I never seen this film but I also
have no idea what it's even about I knew
it had Turla sin it but I had no idea
what part he even played and so the
story itself begins with a pod landing
on earth while the gang excluding Goku
is camping in the forest this forest
suddenly bursts into flames some of the
colors and visuals with Gohan and
krillen tackling the burning woodland
are actually very pretty with the
inferno eventually having come under
control the forest itself is left in
ashes leaving all the native creatures
without a place to live and thus the
quest for the Dragon Balls begins q
theme music
and so naturally this film is pretty
much a quest to find all seven
dragonballs always no it's not the title
sequence ends and Shenron is here oh and
it's that shot from the old opening on
Toonami the vast majority of the first
15 minutes isn't important and Icarus
for the most part gets way too much
screen time that culminates in what is
eventually a throwaway scene towards the
end other than that the last 75 percent
of the film is actually handled really
really well if you're a fan of Goku
wrecking shop then you'll love the
middle bit that boasts some of the best
animation this era of Dragon Ball has to
offer
seriously it's utterly gorgeous
additionally and somewhat surprisingly
there's a pretty hefty environmental
message throughout that it works for the
most part the Z Warriors get to get
punched and Taurus is actually much
better and much more fun to watch in
this movie that I anticipated I like the
concept of the tree that sucks the life
out of the planet it makes for a great
visual and a fitting way to cap off the
film with a bang using the life energy
of the tree itself against hurl us and
the tree was a clever idea in what I
didn't see coming
the film has its drawbacks like the
first 15 minutes and King Kai only
appearing to facilitate exposition dumps
but the vast majority of the film is
actually quite fun
next this film I haven't seen but I did
watch the team four star version it's
pretty much the same story for the most
part all the while being less than half
the runtime how is this possible well
the movie just sort of drags its feet
with the forward progression of the
story a bit here and there and
everywhere there are some truly fun
action sequences in the first half with
Gohan Crillon piccolo and even Roshi but
in order to get to those moments there's
tons of unnecessary talking standing
around doing nothing and action with no
resolution the story so far is pretty
sound and perfectly serviceable but the
material is better suited to a 30
minutes special than a 45 minute feature
the Big Daddy star is the most MacGuffin
thing I've heard it all of Dragonball so
far I don't care about it even slightly
and it comes out of nowhere to make the
plot possible the great aspects of this
film are clear as day Vegeta Safer Goku
during the initial phase of the cooter
fight is a highlight for certain however
how he got to the planet that was made
to be intentionally
the find is left unexplained which
always bothered me and that's pretty
much this movie at a nutshell things
sort of happen that wouldn't normally
make sense just to facilitate a cool
shot animation sequence or reveal and
there are some awesome shots in this
film some of my favorites in fact a
wounded Goku Vegeta standing defiantly
against an army of Cooter's is a sweet
shot and it's one Toyota ro took
inspiration from for his manga during
the Goku black arc I would imagine those
of you that enjoy Dragonball for the
fights and not the story will thoroughly
enjoy this and even those of you that
like the banter between Vegeta and Goku
have something to enjoy here as for the
story it's pretty unremarkable overall
with an ending that screams we didn't
know how to end this so goku vegeta just
get super-strong and win inexplicably
and they even had sense of beats what
I watched these movies one after the
other and at the stage in watching these
films I became incredibly jaded super
jaded not necessarily because these
movies are doing anything terribly wrong
but because they are all doing the same
for the most part all them follow this
basic structure cold-open with the gang
enjoying normal things injecting bits of
comedy the bad guy shows up and they
fight for the vast majority with the
goal of stopping them they keep fighting
until they fail then Goku pulls through
at the end to win the day inexplicably
the story isn't necessarily there to be
interesting or captivating but to act as
a vehicle for the action to take place
it's action / story and honestly I'm
sick of it now this film has some great
visuals the character designs are quirky
and I really like how they reanimated
Android 17 eliminating dr. Gero at the
very beginning but when you catch on to
how these films are structured which
isn't difficult they become very slow
and boring to watch there's no emotional
through-line to keep tabs with and to
explore it's punch punch
shout shout repeat until over Dragon
Ball sort of has this reputation for
being the punch kick shout anime and
wild to action is a large part of the
series it's by no means ever been the
focus of it the action happens but the
story has always been first they tell a
story through the fighting they don't
just have a story so that they can fight
and that is the key difference the super
Android 13 film itself has terrific
backgrounds and colors going its way and
the art from this era is always reliable
but the story has nothing to say it
might as well be a sequence of clips
clips that on their own look great and
are cool but offer nothing else once
again because the story has no emotional
through-line it has to figure out a way
for go for the super punch the bad guy
away at the end that really screams deus
ex machina from a visual front that's up
there with the standard classic Dragon
Ball has always enjoyed but in terms of
story it offers nothing please Lord let
this next one have a story
I immediately hated this Gohan whistling
thing makes me so uncomfortable for some
reason more so than it does piccolo the
tune is unbearable to me moving swiftly
on this is another one of those
Dragonball movies I have no idea about
or what the story even is so a massive
common expected to crash on earth
explodes near it instead releasing a
spaceship that lands on the planet
within this ship you guessed it is none
other than the titular Lord slug and his
henchmen looking to you guessed it
gathered the earth Dragon Balls - you
guessed it grant Lord slug immortality
oh wait no he wants to be young sort of
a waste but you know whatever it's your
wish his primary goal for Earth is to
convert it into a ship or vehicle to
cruise across the universe or something
what's important is that he's doing bad
things to the earth and boy how many
does Goku and ko want to stop him some
of the henchmen piccolo and Gohan face
have some pretty interesting and
somewhat gross abilities so that's
always fun nevertheless Goku shows up to
make the save for piccolo and Gohan that
leads to the henchmans ultimate to feast
in a style that is very similar to how
he arrived and defeated the ginyu force
anomic definitely not a coincidence most
of these films do these things like this
and with the henchmen out of the way
it's time for the main course it's slug
time the fight honestly early on is very
standard Crillon gets decked in one
punch and Goku takes the beating for the
bones of ten minutes until this happens
Goku ends up doing this sort of super
sand but not really kind of thing it's a
really cool scene and demonstration of
the form except the hair is the wrong
color I don't know enough about the
scene and its production but I've heard
that this was a mistake by the art
department and this was supposed to be
the first Super Saiyan demonstration but
fell short as a result of the color
mishap this could be untrue I am by no
means an official source I haven't fact
checked this but that's just something
that I've heard it's a rumor or maybe
it's true I don't know regardless it
turns out that slug is in the Meccan
which explains why he knows about the
Dragon Balls and he begins to grow in
size much like piccolo did during the
Tenkaichi Budokai there's some
interesting shots of Goku running and
evading the giant hands of slug with
some interesting action sequences from
piccolo himself also they then tank the
entire film by making it such that
Gohan's whistling is the kryptonite to
the namekian people piccolo rips his
ears off and go on we can slug through
his terrible whistling now having being
weakened Goku gives Lord slug the old
wham bam thank you ma'am sending him
away with a spirit bomb overall the
movie is OK it's very formulaic with
some cool visual moments the ending is
honestly terrible due to their being
primarily no emotional through lines
shocking I know and now it's time for
that movie I've been dreading to review
this entire time ruling Second Coming is
the most bonkers film I've ever seen
released for Dragonball Bar None and
I've seen Hitler resurrect from the dead
while Goku Vegeta try to fix the
plumbing in other world at the end of
the first bro Lee film we are expected
to believe that not only did Rolly land
in ice crystal that regardless of what
it is should have no oxygen for him to
breathe and does should have killed him
there and then but that's not where this
crazy train of coincidence ends he also
landed on earth of all places
coincidentally residing in the lake that
also happens to be where a beast
terrorizes a small village in the middle
of nowhere a place that vidal Goten and
Trunks
happened to find themselves sitting on
top of all the while managing to make
the only noise that could wake up this
comatose Broly this is the single most
tragic opening I've ever seen in my life
and then this
what is happening what is happening in
this movie it's like a funhouse mirror
nothing is the way that you think it
should be I like that Vidal has a large
role to play in this film but she hasn't
been set up to survive a single shot
from the character that did this to
Vegeta in the last one Gohan senses a
disturbance in the force and begins
racing towards location of all the
action arriving just in the nick of time
to make the save on Goten and Trunks and
this is honestly the best part of the
film for me scene go on acting
assertively and assuming responsibility
for everyone taking the lead against
Broly but truly that's not nearly enough
to make this even a passable film for me
suffering similar issues other films in
this series have had to an absurd degree
this film takes so many liberties with
its storytelling in order to exclusively
create snapshot moments that are cool in
isolation but when you stop to think
about it makes zero sense
for instance this shot of Goten go on
and Goku firing a family Kamehameha was
awesome it's a shot that is shared
throughout the internet ads will I am
very familiar with now having seen it I
can't help but laugh at it the Dragon
Balls fall out of a bag Shenron summons
himself and goku is wish backed by what
is later explained as the dragon himself
helping out Goku I've heard people say
that Goten makes the wish but he really
doesn't he doesn't say a single word any
monologue that happens with Goten
happens in his head and you can't make a
wish with what you're thinking otherwise
what would have been the point of the
very first wish and all of Dragon Ball
work along wished for panties I'm sure
no one else was thinking that it's
always been very clearly a first-come
first-serve audible request to the
Dragon from you the person making the
wish and so as Goku makes his way up to
his two sons I am laughing at how
utterly ridiculous this entire thing is
why not have Fidel use the balls she was
the one that wanted to see them in
action in the first place
and it would have given her a unique and
worthwhile use in the film what in the
world were they thinking between this
and Bojack and bound surprise Goku saved
the endings
his films receive are some of the worst
deus ex machina finishes i had ever sat
through this movie had some great ideas
for visuals but cared less about the
story than pretty much all of the others
look I love Dragon Balls big moments as
much as the next guy my favorite happens
to be right now the kaio-ken times 20 on
Namek but that moment is so great
because of everything that went into
making it what it was in isolation as a
vapid meaningless action sequence it
loses a ton of its luster for me and the
same can be said for why the Gohan Super
Saiyan 2 transformation was so
successful it's not just successful
because it looks cool it's successful
because of what it means it meant
something
this Broly film didn't pay enough
attention or give enough care to what
ultimately became a very bad script a
script that could be made infinitely
better with a few minor changes here and
there without yet again relying on the
old reliable or as bro lame I putted
Kakarot Kakarot Kakarot Kakarot my
journey through these films have been
much more enjoyable than what this video
might have led you to believe there were
some pleasant surprises earlier in this
series but if I'm being perfectly honest
the vast majority follow the exact same
formulaic structure that honestly bores
me to death and don't get me wrong I'm
by no means saying that you can't enjoy
these as I said earlier if you're just
in this for the action it's there just
don't expect anything in the realm of
story for the vast majority of these
I've made a list of these films from
best to worst as my personal ranking and
posted it on my Twitter if you want to
check that out and maybe give me a
follow I'm on their ass totally not Marc
lots of the concepts I employ for videos
come from your input on Twitter and make
sure to subscribe for more videos on
YouTube too but now I'll do for this
week thank you all so much for watching
[Music]